מדידה של סופרפוזיציה קוונטית היא אקראית כמו הטלת מטבע, אבל עד כמה אפשר למתוח את האנלוגיה הזו לפני שהיא נשברת
נגלה את זה היום ב-Qiskit in the
Classroom ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit in the Classroom, סדרת וידאו שבה אנחנו מפרקים מושג בסיסי שאתם
עשויים להיתקל בו בקורס שקשור למחשוב קוונטי. כל סרטון מלווה במודול אינטראקטיבי שמקושר
בתיאור למטה, אז בטוח תבדקו את זה. היום אנחנו מדברים על אחד מעקרונות הליבה שנמצאים בלב
התאוריה הקוונטית - סופרפוזיציה. בחוויה היומיומית שלנו, לעצמים תמיד יש תכונות מוגדרות: המיקום שלהם, הגודל,
הצורה, הצבע - הכל לגביהם הוא מוגדר וודאי, גם אם אנחנו כצופים עדיין לא מדדנו את זה. בעולם
הקוונטי זה לא בהכרח המצב. עצם קוונטי יכול להיות במשהו שנקרא סופרפוזיציה של
מספר מצבים קלאסיים מותרים, שכאשר מודדים אותו יתמוטט באופן אקראי לאחד מהמצבים
האלה. מדידה של מצב סופרפוזיציה היא כמו הטלת מטבע - אין דרך לדעת מראש לאיזה צד הוא
ייפול. האי-דטרמיניזם הבסיסי הזה הוא היבט לא נוח של מכניקת הקוונטים שאפילו איינשטיין התקשה
איתו. הוא אמר את המשפט המפורסם "אלוהים לא משחק בקוביות" על האקראיות הזו, אבל כפי שנראה, אלוהים בעצם כן משחק בקוביות, או במקרה
שלנו הוא מטיל מטבעות. אבל יותר מזה, המטבעות האלה מכוונים. מדידה של סופרפוזיציה קוונטית אולי דומה
להטלת מטבע במובנים מסוימים, אבל הסופרפוזיציה עצמה הרבה יותר עשירה ומורכבת ממצב
הסתברותי קלאסי. כדי לראות את זה, אנחנו הולכים לחשוב איך מטבע קלאסי עובד ולהשוות את זה עם המטבע
הקוונטי שלנו שנחקור באמצעות Qiskit על מחשב קוונטי של IBM. ראשית, מטבע קלאסי - זה
די פשוט. מטילים את המטבע והוא נופל עם הפנים למעלה או הפנים למטה עם סיכוי של 50% לכל צד. בעיקרון אנחנו יכולים
לחשב לאיזה צד המטבע ייפול אם היינו יודעים את התנאים ההתחלתיים המדויקים של המטבע ובדיוק כמה
כוח ומומנט הופעלו במהלך ההטלה, אבל בפרקטיקה אין דרך לדעת מראש לאיזה צד
המטבע ייפול. לכן אנחנו משתמשים בהטלת מטבע כדוגמה הקנונית למצב הסתברותי קלאסי שבו
התוצאה היא למעשה אקראית. אם הייתי מטיל את המטבע הזה אלף פעמים ורושם את מספר הפנים למעלה
ופנים למטה, הייתי מקבל היסטוגרמה שנראית בערך ככה, אז יש לנו ספירות על ציר
ה-Y וזה יכול להיות או פנים למעלה או פנים למטה
וההיסטוגרמה הייתה מראה שיש בערך 500 ספירות מכל סוג, עד כדי תנודה
סטטיסטית. אנחנו יכולים ליצור מצב דומה באמצעות qubit במחשב הקוונטי שלנו. כמו הטלת המטבע,
qubit גם יכול להימדד בשני מצבים אפשריים - אפס ואחד. אם נפעיל משהו שנקרא Hadamard gate על
ה-qubit, זה ישים אותו בסופרפוזיציה שווה של אפס ואחד. הנה
ויזואליזציה של ה-circuit הזה, שאנחנו קוראים לו circuit diagram. כאן החוט העליון הוא
ה-qubit והפעולות שמופעלות על ה-qubit מופיעות כתיבות על החוטים. ה-Hadamard gate מוצג עם התיבה הזו
שמסומנת H והמדידה מוצגת עם התיבה האפורה הזו שמסומנת עם סמל המדידה הקטן. היא שולחת את
המדידה לביט קלאסי - החוט הזה עם שני הקווים. אז מכיוון שה-qubit נמצא בסופרפוזיציה שווה של 0 ו-1, כשאנחנו
מודדים אותו יש סיכוי של 50% שנמדוד אפס ו-50% שנמדוד
אחד. אנחנו מבטאים את מצב הסופרפוזיציה הקוונטי הזה כ-s = 1 / <
tk2 0 + 1 / < tk2 1 כאשר הריבועים של כל אחד מה
מקדמים האלה, שנקראים גם אמפליטודות, הם ההסתברויות למדוד כל מצב. אז בעצם הפעלת ה-Hadamard
gate היא האנלוגיה להטלת מטבע, ובדיוק כמו שהטלנו את המטבע אלף פעמים כדי לבחון את
הסטטיסטיקה של נחיתת המטבע על פנים למעלה או פנים למטה, אנחנו יכולים לעשות משהו דומה ב-Qiskit עם המטבע הקוונטי שלנו.
נשתמש בפרימיטיב של Qiskit שנקרא sampler שיחזור על ה-circuit מספר פעמים כדי לדגום את הסטטיסטיקה
של המצב המתקבל. עם אלף דגימות מה-circuit שלמעלה, יש לנו משהו שנראה כמעט זהה
להיסטוגרמה של המטבע הקלאסי, עד כדי תנודה סטטיסטית. אז זהו? סופרפוזיציות
קוונטיות הן בעצם אותו דבר כמו מצב הסתברותי קלאסי, בדומה להטלת מטבע? לא בדיוק. זה היה
סרטון די קצר אם זה היה המצב. כדי לראות את ההבדל המרכזי הראשון אני הולך לנסות משהו קצת אחר עם המטבע הקלאסי שלי. במקום
פשוט לתת לו ליפול על השולחן ולנחות על פנים למעלה או למטה, אני הולך להטיל את המטבע ולתפוס אותו
באוויר בין כפות הידיים. עכשיו המטבע הוא לא פנים למעלה או למטה, אלא הפנים שמאלה
או ימינה. אז ההיגיון אומר שגם לזה צריכה להיות הסתברות של 50/50 שיהיה
פנים שמאלה או ימינה. כדי למדוד פנים שמאלה או ימינה על המטבע הקוונטי שלנו, אנחנו יכולים לעשות מה שעשינו עם המטבע הקלאסי -
למדוד לאורך ציר אחר. המדידות הסטנדרטיות שלנו במחשב הקוונטי הן לאורך הציר האנכי,
בדיוק כמו מדידת הפנים למעלה או למטה הרגילה של המטבע הקלאסי, אבל אנחנו יכולים גם לשאול את המטבע הקוונטי שלנו אם הוא
פנים שמאלה או ימינה. אנחנו קוראים לשני המצבים האלה לאורך ציר ה-X פלוס או מינוס.
לשם כך נשתמש בפרימיטיב של Qiskit שנקרא estimator. כדי לסבך את העניינים קצת, במקום להחזיר היסטוגרמה כמו
ש-sampler עושה, estimator ייתן לנו את מה שנקרא ערך הציפייה של כל observable של ה-qubit. כדי
להבין את ערך הציפייה הזה, נגיד שאתם מקבלים דולר כל פעם שהמטבע נופל על פנים למעלה ומפסידים דולר כשהוא
נופל על פנים למטה. ערך הציפייה הוא כמה כסף אתם יכולים לצפות להרוויח בממוצע בכל הטלה. מכיוון
שיש סיכוי שווה להרוויח או להפסיד דולר, ערך הציפייה יהיה אפס. אותו היגיון חל
על ה-qubit. כשאנחנו מוצאים את ערך הציפייה של X - כשמפעילים X על מצב פלוס
מקבלים ערך של פלוס אחד, ועל מצב מינוס מקבלים מינוס אחד. אז אם הייתה לנו
התפלגות 50/50, היינו מקבלים ערך ציפייה של אפס. אבל לא מקבלים - מקבלים ערך ציפייה של פלוס אחד,
כלומר המטבע תמיד נמדד כפלוס לאורך ציר ה-X. זה היה כמו להטיל
מטבע, לתפוס אותו באוויר, ולהבטיח שהפנים תמיד יפנו ימינה. הסיבה לזה היא ש
סופרפוזיציה היא לא רק התפלגות הסתברות. תזכרו איך ביטאנו מצב קוונטי:
s שווה ל-C0 כפול מצב 0 ועוד C1
כפול מצב 1, כאשר כל אחד מהמקדמים האלה הוא מרוכב, כלומר יש להם
חלק ממשי וחלק מדומה. אז הם מספרים לנו על ההסתברויות, אבל הם גם מסתירים גודל נוסף שנקרא
הפאזה. מקדם C כלשהו אפשר לכתוב
ככה: C שווה לגודל כפול הפאזה הזו, כאשר פי הזה הוא
הפאזה. זה קצת כמו הפאזה של גל, או המיקום של פסגות ושקעים של הגל. אם שני גלים הם בפאזה
אחד עם השני, כלומר הפסגות והשקעים שלהם מיושרים, אז הם יתחברו ליצור גל בגובה
כפול. אנחנו קוראים לזה התאבכות בונה. אם הם לא בפאזה, כמו
ככה, אז הם מתאבכים באופן הורס ומבטלים לגמרי אחד את השני. כדי לראות איך הפאזה יכולה לגרום
להתאבכות במטבע הקוונטי שלנו, בואו ננסה להפעיל את ה-Hadamard פעמיים במקום רק פעם אחת. עכשיו, קלאסית
זה לא הגיוני - אם הפעלת ה-Hadamard שקולה להטלת מטבע, אז אי אפשר להטיל מטבע שכבר מסתובב באוויר. אבל בואו נראה מה
קורה מבחינה קוונטית. אז מפעילים את ה-Hadamard פעמיים ודוגמים את המצב המתקבל.
מדהים - כבר אין לנו הסתברות 50/50. ההיסטוגרמה המתקבלת מראה שבכל המקרים אנחנו מודדים את
ה-qubit במצב אפס. אז ה-Hadamard השני החזיר את ה-qubit למצב אפס שבו התחלנו. זה
קצת מסובך לראות בהתחלה, אבל זה הודות להתאבכות של המצב הקוונטי. אבל במקום
להתאבך במרחב אמיתי כמו גל ממשי, ההתאבכות קורה במרחב המידע המופשט של ה-qubit.
ה-Hadamard gate השני גרם לחלק האפס של הסופרפוזיציה להתאבך באופן בונה, בעוד שחלק האחד של
הסופרפוזיציה התאבך באופן הורס ונעלם. בואו נחקור עוד - אנחנו יכולים לשנות את הפאזה באמצעות
משהו שנקרא phase gate. אז עכשיו בואו נפעיל Hadamard כדי ליצור את הסופרפוזיציה, נפעיל הזזת פאזה של
פאי רדיאנים, ואז נפעיל את ה-Hadamard השני. עכשיו נראה שהמטבע הקוונטי שלנו תמיד יוצא במצב אחד.
הזזת הפאזה של פאי החליפה את החלקים של מצב הסופרפוזיציה שהיו בפאזה ומחוץ לפאזה אחד עם השני.
אז המצב הסופי הוא אחד במקום אפס. זה היה כמו להטיל מטבע וכשהוא באוויר להיות מסוגלים
איכשהו להפעיל פעולה שמבטיחה שהוא תמיד ינחת על פנים למעלה או תמיד על פנים למטה, תלוי
בפעולה. בלתי אפשרי במקרה הקלאסי, אבל לא במקרה הקוונטי. מה שלמדנו מהניסויים האלה הוא
שהיכולת החדשה הזו של המטבע הקוונטי נובעת מהפאזה שלו - תכונה שלסופרפוזיציה קוונטית יש אבל
להתפלגות הסתברות קלאסית אין. אז הטלת מטבע רגילה היא בעצם לא אנלוגיה כל כך טובה
לסופרפוזיציה, כי היא לא אומרת שום דבר על הפאזה הזו. אני חושב שאפשר לעשות יותר טוב. אני הולך לעשות עוד
ניסוי עם המטבע שלנו. המטבע יושב על השולחן עם הפנים למעלה. כדי להפוך אותו לפנים למטה, אני פשוט יכול להפוך אותו. זה
המקבילה החישובית של NOT gate. נגיד שאנחנו רוצים לבנות פעולה שאם מפעילים אותה פעמיים תהיה
שקולה ל-NOT gate הזה. אנחנו יכולים לקרוא לפעולה הזו שורש של NOT. אז חשבו על מה שאנחנו פיזית עושים
כשמפעילים את ה-NOT gate - אנחנו מסובבים אותו 180 מעלות סביב, למשל, ציר ה-X. אז אם נסובב את המטבע
רק 90 מעלות סביב ציר ה-X, זה ייתן לנו את שורש ה-NOT. אז הפעלנו
את שורש ה-NOT והמטבע פשוט יושב על הקצה שלו. עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לשאול - האם הוא פנים למעלה או פנים למטה? ובכן,
ברור שלא זה ולא זה. אבל אנחנו יכולים להוסיף שלב לתהליך המדידה כדי להכריח אותו להיות פנים למעלה או למטה. עכשיו
המטבע ייפול לצד פנים למעלה או פנים למטה עם הסתברות שווה. שוב, בעיקרון אפשר לחזות
לאיזה צד הוא ייפול, אבל בפרקטיקה זה מספיק קשה לחיזוי כדי להיות למעשה אקראי. אם אני רוצה
למדוד אם הוא פנים שמאלה או ימינה, אני יכול ללחוץ עליו בכיוון הזה באופן דומה, וזה שוב ייתן לנו
הסתברות 50/50 של שמאל וימין. אבל בממד הזה - פנים קדימה או אחורה -
הפנים כבר מופנות קדימה, אז ב-100% מהמקרים נמדוד פנים קדימה. אז בעוד שמדידות ה-X וה-Z
נתנו תוצאות אקראיות, מדידת ה-Y תמיד תיתן את אותה תוצאה. אם נחשוב אחורה על
ניסוי הטלת המטבע הקוונטי מהחלק הקודם, זה מזכיר את האופן שבו המטבע הקוונטי התנהג אחרי
הפעלת ה-Hadamard. ה-qubit נמדד כאפס או אחד עם הסתברות 50/50 בכיוון Z, אבל
תמיד במצב פלוס ולעולם לא במצב מינוס לאורך X. זה מרמז שאולי מטבע שעומד על הקצה שלו
הוא דרך טובה יותר לדמיין מצב סופרפוזיציה של qubit, מאשר מטבע שמסתובב באוויר.
בואו נפעיל שורש של NOT gate על המטבע הקוונטי שלנו. ב-Qiskit יש לנו את ה-circuit הפשוט
הזה. ואז נשתמש ב-estimator כדי לבדוק את ערך הציפייה של שלושת ה-observables: X, Y ו-Z, שזה בערך
כמו למחוץ את המטבע שלנו לאורך כל אחד משלושת הממדים, כמו שהרגע הראיתי. אז ערכי הציפייה הם 0,
מינוס אחד ו-0 עבור X, Y ו-Z בהתאמה. זו אותה תוצאה שקיבלנו
עבור סיבוב שורש ה-NOT שהופעל על המטבע הקלאסי. למעשה יש אנלוגיה מדויקת בין
המטבע לבין מצב ה-qubit. עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לדמיין את מצב ה-qubit כווקטור שמצביע בכיוון הפנים
על המטבע, ניצב לפני השטח של המטבע. אז פנים למעלה, או מצב אפס
על המטבע הקוונטי, שקול לווקטור שמצביע ישר למעלה. פנים למטה, או אחד, מצביע ישר למטה. וכל
סופרפוזיציה שווה של 0 ו-1 מצביעה אופקית. הפאזה של המצב הקוונטי קובעת את הכיוון האופקי
המדויק שהוא מצביע אליו - למשל, אם הוא מצביע לאורך ציר ה-X או לאורך ציר ה-Y או אי שם
באמצע. הווקטור הזה ידוע בשם וקטור בלוך, והוא מגדיר באופן מלא וייחודי את המצב הקוונטי של qubit
בודד. עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לדמיין מחדש כל gate שראינו בסרטון הזה כסיבוב או סדרה של סיבובים על
המטבע, או באופן שקול, על וקטור בלוך. ה-NOT gate הוא סיבוב של
180 מעלות סביב ציר ה-X. כשמפעילים אותו על מצב אפס, או פנים למעלה, הוא מתהפך למצב
פנים למטה, או אחד. שורש ה-NOT הוא פשוט 90 מעלות סביב אותו ציר X, מתחילים
ממצב פנים למעלה, וזה מסובב אותו לפנים קדימה. phase gate הוא סיבוב של פי סביב ציר ה-Z. מכיוון ש
פנים למעלה מיושר עם ציר ה-Z, זה לא עושה כלום למטבע. ה-Hadamard gate הוא קצת יותר מסובך. אנחנו
בהתחלה דימינו אותו להטלת מטבע, שגורמת למטבע להסתובב באוויר בצורה בלתי נשלטת, אבל ה-Hadamard הוא בעצם
סיבוב מבוקר ודטרמיניסטי של המטבע, כמו כל ה-gates האחרים. ה-Hadamard מתבצע על ידי סיבוב של 90 מעלות
סביב ציר ה-Y ואז 180 מעלות סביב ציר ה-X. אז כשמפעילים אותו על מצב פנים למעלה, הוא
מגיע למצב פנים ימינה. אז אין שום דבר אקראי במצב סופרפוזיציה קוונטי או באף אחת
מהפעולות הסטנדרטיות שאנחנו מבצעים על ה-qubit. כל פעולה היא דטרמיניסטית והפיכה. הפעם
היחידה שאקראיות נכנסת לתמונה היא כשאנחנו מחליטים למדוד את המצב הקוונטי. האם מצב קוונטי בכלל נמצא
בסופרפוזיציה זה באמת עניין של נקודת מבט. כפי שכנראה נתקלתם, אנחנו חופשיים לבחור את מערכת
הקואורדינטות שלנו - X, Y ו-Z יכולים להצביע לאורך כל שלושה כיוונים ניצבים. אז
אם יש לנו סופרפוזיציה של 0 ו-1 במערכת קואורדינטות אחת, אנחנו יכולים להגדיר מערכת קואורדינטות חדשה, או מה שנקרא
בסיס, שבה המצב מצביע רק בכיוון פלוס Z ולכן לא נמצא במצב סופרפוזיציה.
אז כשאנחנו אומרים ש-qubit נמצא בסופרפוזיציה, אנחנו חייבים גם להגדיר את מערכת הקואורדינטות שלנו, או
הבסיס. אתם אולי יוצאים מהמודול הזה עם הרושם שפשוט הסרנו את כל המסתורין ממכניקת הקוונטים,
אחרי הכל, אחד מההיבטים שנחשבים הכי מוזרים - מצב הסופרפוזיציה של qubit - הוא באמת פשוט כמו
וקטור תלת-ממדי. אבל זכרו שהמטבע הוא עדיין רק אנלוגיה, וגם וקטור בלוך הוא
רק כלי ויזואליזציה לחישוב ההסתברויות של תוצאות המדידה. אנחנו לא יכולים לומר מה מצב קוונטי
באמת עושה לפני שמודדים אותו, כי לבדוק את זה דורש מדידה. אנחנו נדון בדילמה
הזו של מה הטבע האמיתי של מצב קוונטי ואיך התופעה הקוונטית של שזירה יכולה לעזור לנו
להבהיר את זה, בפרק אחר של Qiskit in the Classroom שעוסק באי-שוויון של Bell. בינתיים, אם אתם
רוצים לשחק עם מטבעות קוונטיים כדי ללמוד בעצמכם על מצבי הסופרפוזיציה של qubit ואיך לשלוט
בהם, כנסו למודול המטבעות הקוונטיים שמקושר בתיאור. תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה